[Musique]
je m'appelle marine karmitz je suis
cinéaste
je ne suis pas un collectionneur je suis
un amateur
[Musique]
c'est par la collection que la
production du tout c'est la proximité et
le l'amitié l'affection que je peux
avoir à l'égard de l'oeuvre c'est pour
moi des oeuvres que en gros je vais
saluer tous les matins c'est à dire je
leur dis au revoir avant de partir je
leur ai dit bonjour en rentrant c'est
comme si c'était des personnes vivantes
ça il ya quelque chose qui pour moi est
vraiment de l'ordre du du dialogue et du
mystère je pars de meilleure humeur de
matin après avoir été salué une ou deux
oeuvres
[Musique]
cette série de neuf main s'appelle les
mains de prague son auteur c'est
christian boltanski
voilà un peu l'histoire qui m'a raconté
il est allé visiter la maison de kafka à
prague il a trouvé dans un coin photo
d'un conseil d'administration et il n'a
gardé de ce conseil d'administration que
les mains de ses administrateurs j'ai
l'habitude de me mettre
quand je reçois des gens de mettre face
à ses mains car très souvent si je
m'ennuie
ça me permet de m'évader et de commencer
à me raconter des histoires sans fin
d'ailleurs parce que je n'ai jamais
trouvé
évidemment à qui appartenait ses mains
quels étaient les visages où les corps
qui se cachait derrière donc il ya pour
moi un mystère incroyable qui se dégage
de ses mains
[Musique]
j'aime de moins en moins l'art sans
mystère parce qu'ils restent amis est un
metteur en scène avec qui il travaille
depuis plus de dix ans qui pour moi est
actuellement le oui je pèse mes mots le
plus grand metteur en scéne au monde
j'ai contribué à montrer ses premières
photos à paris avant il était montré
dans les salles dans les entrées des
salles de cinéma où il y avait des
rétrospective de ses films depuis devenu
un artiste très coté sur le marché sur
un faiblard et plusieurs plusieurs
étapes tout d'abord l'étape de metteur
en scène les arts plastiques étaient
relativement second plan s'est
essentiellement concentré sur mon métier
tinner
très vite quand j'ai arrêté de faire des
films s'avérant 74
j'ai commencé à mettre en place des
salles est toujours tenté de faire des
salles de cinéma du lieu de cinéma des
lieux de passerelle entre le cinéma les
arts plastiques la musique la
littérature la poésie la photo etc
et c'est toujours le cas même maintenant
j'ai toujours demandé à des artistes de
participer à cette activité il ya une
autre étape qui s'est déclenchée plus
tard c'est à dire qu'au fur et à mesure
le cinéma a été remplacé par les arts
plastiques
c'est devenu si vous voulez un espèce d
espace pour moi de liberté de plaisir de
désire absolument considérable ça
remplace et beaucoup de choses que le
cinéma m'offrez auparavant hélas ces
deux photos d'un photographe australien
qui s'appelle bill en somme
j'ai été très frappé par là la beauté de
cet essai de photos puisque les deux
sortants contre simple c'est devenu une
photographe très reconnue neuf re doit
pouvoir amener à des à des questions qui
peuvent rester sans réponse mais qu on y
apporte son propre manger c'est à dire
que chacun peut faire des commentaires
qu'il veut mais c'est ce qui m'intéresse
aussi dans cinéma pour moi le grand
cinéma c'est un cinéma très ouvert un
cinéma où chaque spectateur peut
inventer son histoire par rapport au
film qu'il voit être ému faire des
commentaires très différents
[Musique]
vous est demandé de venir ici à la
galerie vu parce que je voulais vous
présenter
christian caujolle et grâce auquel j'ai
découvert la photographie
j'avais une relation avec la
photographie qui a été très distantes
[Musique]
dans une peau lections il ya une façon
de se dévoiler et de faire son portrait
qui est parfois extrêmement
bouleversante choisir une pièce façade
haute face à ceux qui les défendent
c'est se livrer c'est quand même ce
livre est beaucoup dire j'aime ça aux
produits achetés pour vivre avec pas
rien
marine vie avec les heures elle
rassemble ans qui vit avec les hommes
est aussi extrêmement touchante
j'y pense par rapport à une pièce très
particulière d'une pièce extraordinaire
rare et qui l'avait représenté appareil
photo c'est une pièce d'antoine d'agata
et c'est son seul panneau qui défait qui
étudierait une thématique très lié à
l'histoire marine s'était intéressée
tout de suite au travail et d'antoine et
je me disais je pense ça devrait toucher
mind ça a pas raté pareille photo a
ouvert
marie-mai passées sur le stand et à
acheter toute fille de cet âge
cette pièce et ça ça me faisait ça m'a
fait très plaisir
pas parce que marine avait acheté parce
qu'on avait vendu une pièce mais parce
que j'avais le sentiment que c'était
quelque chose qui lui correspondait
profondément on se trompe bien sûr après
chacun a le droit
heureusement devenir et marine m'a dit
certaines fois et ça j'aime pas ça et je
trouve ça formidable
une oeuvre existe il ya un passeur il ya
quelqu'un qui est là pour pour s'en
occuper pour qu'elle ne soit pas
orpheline qu'elle ne soit pas dans un
coin etc et ce passeur 7 7
c'est ce personnage entre deux vins vers
ce qu'on appelle un collectionneur en
amateur ou des musées etc ou des eaux
des livres des éditeurs de livres pour
que cette oeuvre se met à vivre
sans passeur il y aurait peut-être il y
aurait sans doute moins d'artistes il y
aurait certainement beaucoup moins de
collectionner
[Musique]
demandé s'il y avait des photos de trois
hommes disent ils
c'est muñoz la honte non non c'est à
carman ont réagi face à une chose qui
est d'ailleurs un objet qui encadrent et
qui qui qui vous présente l'image qui a
été fait par quelqu'un on réagit et puis
on se pose la question de savoir
pourquoi on réagit pourquoi elles vous
touchent
y'a pas de y'a pas de formule miracle il
faut il faut voir commencer par voir
il portait de plus en plus d'attention à
cet apprentissage du regard il faut
apprendre à voir comment apprendre comme
on apprend à parler comme on apprend à
lire comment apprendre à écrire
on apprend aussi à voir et donc il faut
que cet apprentissage et lieu c'est que
je suis touché déjà première premiers
instants ensuite pourquoi je suis touché
ensuite est ce que est ce qu'il n'ya pas
quelque chose qui peut être plus évoluer
ce qui à part des autres choses c'est
curiosité je le désire nous devons tous
continuer apprentis nom devient dur
devient des vieux cons assez
rédhibitoire
c'est à dire les mecs qui sont arrêtées
à un moment c'est à chier quoi vraiment
ça l'art il permet pas ça l'art et la
création c'est un mouvement mais c'est
un mouvement qui va toujours de l'avant
vous arrêtez vous êtes resté au bord de
la route que vous vouliez passer les
trains est bon c'est pas dans
moyennement intéressant
[Musique]
sous les larges pour moi sert à
construire des maisons et chacun apporte
sa pierre à cette maison il faut
apporter une pierre
on peut pas simplement se contenter de
rentrer dans la maison de faire un tour
est de partir chaque artiste doit
apporter sa pierre et danser cette
pierre que ne cherche pas non plus
compris
on y va de ses
valentin suivront
lassé des jeunes galeries et jeune
galeriste donc des jeunes aussi de
jeunes auteurs de jeunes créateurs et ce
qui peut m'intéresser sont des choses
différentes et nouvelles par rapport à
ce que je connais déjà bien ce qui a été
fait et des choses qui tout a plu fonds
avancés un peu
non
les gars isme ce sont des gens qui ont
énormément compté pour moi parce que le
regard à nous transformer mon retard ça
a été le passage d'un regard si vous
voulez vulgaire non mon gros sous
relativement novice vous connaissez du
saut vers la finement et le raffinement
du regard
vous vous souvenez
dessin noir parce
ce qui m'intéresse chez un artiste que
je collectionne c'est d'être sur la
durée de son travail parce que c'est les
champs joie de maintenance et les
évolutions telles crises parfois des
crises sont extrêmement instructives
ça c'est des moments de faiblesse
ces moments de faiblesse que s'exprime
le plus c'est angoisses et plus et aussi
son talent sa capacité de sortir et de
retourner vers ils ont une certaine
direction
la moitié de nos ventes chez le
galeriste samir othman carmine ça c'est
très bon 7000 7000 euros
[Musique]
pour ne peut pas
sans être dans l'histoire de 20 c'est
pas possible c'est par rapport à
l'ancien mauve est dû
si vous croyez que volonté d'être
séparés
gros il faut
voir mes robes aux anciens et de
maîtrise
si possible
fois ce qui manque par exemple ici
danser
tant que j'ai zappé ce qu'ils maîtrisent
pas toujours les bases mêmes de la
peinture le fait que des artistes
s'isole uniquement dans leur art
sans être comment dire irrigué par d
autres formes d'expression et ma vie
contre est catastrophique et c'est un
des phénomènes actuels
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est collectionnez a
commencé à collectionner un
collectionneur c'est un ensemble comme
ça de show de rencontre l'hésitation de
silence parce que c'est un point de
départ pour moi d'un d'un imaginaire que
je construit au fur et à mesure dans ma
tête ou dans mon coeur et dans sa mort
ichi ça m'apporte quelque chose
[Musique]
non mais c'est pas beaucoup soudan
défaite logique mais sûr c'est très
marrant c'est que c'est tout de même
je vois pas trop ce qu'apporte le
cet effet là et
rapport aux photos
réputé des stands est vraiment
vraiment par an
collectionneur peut aider les artistes à
se faire connaître des oeuvres à être vu
c'est les artistes là encore qui
prennent des risques
nous on fait que aimer les risques
qu'ils prennent mais on est propre à
leur place
[Musique]
je peux aider certains artistes être
proche d'eux mais c'est la voix qui
m'intéresse avant tout et ça n'a pu
commencer à se faire que d'abord moment
j'ai commencé à avoir de l'argent
pendant très longtemps on n'avait pas
les premiers à vous que je peux acheter
je les payais pendant sur deux ans j'ai
retrouvé des marchands gino qui j'allais
tous les samedis le rapporter à un
chèque je payais vraiment à tempérament
et puis aussi au fur et à mesure que mon
regard a commencé à s'affiner
[Musique]
absolument tu puisses y en a
de calgary
tout ne se vaut pas
c'est comme un marchand de fromages et
marchand de fromages la recherche de
parrainages
c'est un peu
comme de respirer c'est des respirations
qui me qui me soit sûr nécessaire c'est
non j'étouffe il faut que je que je
trouve le temps entre deux rendez vous
entre deux ans merde entre deux de casse
tête
deux choses désagréables jeu
je viens me ressourcer je viens de
prendre de l'air c'est un bonheur absolu
là c'est tout ce que j'aime
je m'attendais pas à ça plus vite
[Musique]
je suis dans une position de voyeur
d'une certaine façon d'amateurs jeu
j'apprends et catherine m'aide à
apprendre mais llc moi je sais pas donc
si vous voulez la différence est très
grande
elle a appris elle fait passer elle fait
passer son savoir et ses connaissances
moi je découvre que c'est très important
d'avoir la culture d'un mouvement ou
d'une ou d'une émotion mais aussi de
pouvoir les rapprocher toujours ça sert
à soi même parce qu'on vous la face pas
aussi voyez on ne prend pas comme en
argent comptant une chose qu'on vous
impose
en fait ça permet ça
[Musique]
c'est 1912 s'annonce et tout est
1912 et c'est un artiste à peine
stanisavljevic là c'est quelque chose
qui fut inique pour moi c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne peut voir dans aucun
musée c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
alors pour pour despourrins un amateur
comme moi ah ça c'est s'aider trésor
absolu
ça c'est le musée d'orsay il serait
content d'avoir ça va aussi
est ce assez
c'est des prix qui dépassent les moyens
toi c c'est carrément chef-d'oeuvre ne
pas l'avoir chez soi c'est pas c'est pas
grave c'est déjà de pouvoir le voir
c'est un travail colossal pour arriver à
réunir 10 photos comme ça ça n'existe je
crois que ça n'existe donc amusé à faire
après amusé nasa dire c'est pour être
vraiment hallucinant j'ai cherché une
photo par une photo j'ai cherché en
pologne c'est chercher aux états unis et
au bout d'un moment c'est j'ai pu
reconstruire un peu cette année là si
vous voulez ce moment-là de la photo
c'est absolument pionniers tous les ce
et pas simplement les photographes les
artistes voient ça c'était comme l'image
même de l'émotion tout la faute aux
modernes se trouve là
j'ai des coups de coeur parfois taxé
vraiment envie de quelque chose mais
très souvent j'ai besoin de revenir j'ai
besoin de laisser dormir les bébés
besoin de rêver s'ils voulaient que tout
à coup dans l'inconscient ce l'oeuvre se
mettre en place dans ma propre histoire
justement comment est ce qu elle comment
est ce qu elle comment est ce qu'elle me
parle laisser venir l'émotion est ce que
ça tient ou est ce que ça ne tient par
est ce que c est ce que je me suis dans
un effet de mode ou au contraire quelque
chose qui s'inscrit dans une rigueur et
dans une profondeur donc il faut du
temps vous faites souvent les choses
avec un lien de construction ou dit ah
tiens ça j'allais retrouver la sage les
vues dans ce que j'ai j'avais pas vu cet
aspect de cette heure avant de voir
celle là oui c'est pas de vous non pilée
pas ça c'est ça c'est magnifique pour
moi dans les relations
avec ce que j'appelle les passeurs ce
qui apporte c'est l'espace qui me laisse
les autres pour moi ces démarches on les
essaie de me vendre quelque chose et ça
je gérard de ça parce que je sais que je
ne pourrai pas voir une oeuvre dans mon
rythme dans mon espace à moi marine un
mythe de l'artiste
bien qu'il ne soit pas il n'est pas de
copinage avec les artistes c'est pas du
tout son histoire méconnaître les av
c'est vraiment ce qu'ils et elles
fondent marine et pas avant tout
collectionneur il veut pas d'abord la
posséder même si après et en a besoin
il veut d'abord la comprendre d'abord la
construire avec et on parle peu d'argent
d'abord il a fait le tour de la v après
il voit s'il peut l'acquérir mais j'aime
beaucoup le silence j'ai d'ailleurs fait
une exposition comme commissaire
d'exposition qui s'appelle silence au
pluriel
[Musique]
contexte de l'exposition c'est tout des
oeuvres majeures sont à niveau qui est
exceptionnel cash d'ici de mettre ses
oeuvres de façon à ce qu'elle tienne les
unes par rapport aux autres et c'est
très compliqué quand vous avez 15 très
grands auteurs venant du monde entier de
faire en sorte qu'il n'y paraît qu'ils
se fassent écraser par les autres donc
ça veut dire qu'ils tiennent
certainement le coup les uns par rapport
aux autres intérieurs
c'est une de mes idoles c'est pourquoi
ici je l' ai vu dans une foi qui la
foire de bâle et
au lieu de milliers de milliers de
tableaux de photos et tout à coup
traitée mais totalement saisi par la
force de l'oeuvre avant même de
comprendre ce qu'elle voulait dire
le premier élément c'était le choc
visuel que ce qu'ils avaient à
l'intérieur de tout ça ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas la référence
historique c'est la capacité d'un
artiste à être universel ou cosmopolite
ou en tout cas en dehors de l'anecdote
je n'aime pas les truqueurs les gens qui
utilisent la mode ou les marchés je
n'aime pas les faux qu'on prend pour du
vrai cette offre je les trouvais la fiac
il ya très longtemps je n'ai pas du tout
ces hauteurs de plafond je n'ai pas la
possibilité d'avoir un rayon lumineux
parce que je me suis évidemment son
appartement où il ya les halles de la
lumière vint journée donc on n'a pas cet
effet de l'ombre qui projetait qui très
importante pour pour l'oeuvre a été fait
avec son ombre
ce qui m'a frappé dans cette oeuvre
quand j'ai vu pour la première fois
c'est très difficile à chaque fois c'est
très difficile à expliquer il ya un choc
par exemple là je la revois vraiment
autrement que là où elle était chez moi
et la lfp aux autres mois puisqu'il ya
une hauteur dans une situation qui n'est
pas la même que
celle que de fait chez moi
un collectionneur c'est quelqu'un qui a
un oeil et c'est oeil
il doit le montrer aux autres et donc en
effet un collectionneur doit acheter des
oeuvres des collections privées doivent
exister c'est parce qu'il ya des
collections c'est avec une grande partie
des oeuvres ont été conservés c'est pas
toujours les collections publiques ont
conservé les mêmes les oeuvres les plus
intéressantes mais un collectionneur
privé doit prêter ses oeuvres en
qu'elles soient montrés et au moment où
elles sont montrés elle nécessite en
effet un espace particulier que le
collectionneur ne veut pas la voir chez
lui je n'éprouve aucun plaisir à prêter
des sommes non annoncée s'est passé pas
du tout un plaisir c'est une obligation
je pense qu'une oeuvre doit être doit
doit être existent pour être vu
[Musique]
c'est très rarement et les rues de cette
façon
les oeuvres de giacometti peu désespérée
de face ou pour les éclaire sur les
horaires les emplois là mais je pense à
régler mais on a mis une langue un an
que tu étais un peu plein
[Musique]
là ce que vous voyez n'est pas terminé
il est en train d'être mise en place
et c'est une plage lui manque quelques
accessoires sur cette page la musique
il manque un jukebox c'est une pièce
sonore pour la conserver on ne devrait
pas l'éclairer c'est là que les
conservateurs disent il faut pas
l'équerré et donc nous on a obtenu donc
de l'auteur qui pourtant dans les plus
propriétaire il dégage la responsabilité
du centre pompidou en acceptant qu'elles
soient éclairés comme lui la voyait en
1962 place d'un collectionneur public
donc acheté l'oeuvre privée donc de
martial raysse qui la stocke dans des
règles générales de conservation et qui
interdit qu'elle se montrer comme
l'artiste le voulait alors que si ça
avait été une pièce appartenant invitons
à marine car mission d'autres
collectionneurs
il aurait donc jamais posé cette
question il n'aura exposés tels que
l'artiste le voulait et donc on l'a
réussi puisque est drôle c'est que c'est
la première fois qu'elle explosait comme
ça ce qu'elle a déjà été exposée au
centre pompidou pas éclairé et un jeune
conservateur du centre pompidou la prend
pour le centre pompidou metz il aveux
comme ça
j'ai pas envie de fondation j'ai pas
envie de deux grandes burnes funéraire à
mon nom avec fondation atteindre cet
état je pense qu'on ne transmet pas les
oeuvres des autres on transmet ses
propres offres
j'ai fait des choses dans ma vie j'ai
fait des choses dans le cinéma c'est mon
métier ça je suis très soucieux de
transmettre ce que j'ai fait dans le
cinéma
les oeuvres que j'ai pu acquérir ces les
oeuvres d'autres dont ses oeuvres sont à
tout le monde
il faut simplement les respecter les
traités correctement
la part les mépriser une vie sans arêtes
une vie d'un morte
alors c'est vrai que il ya beaucoup d'un
morte
donc comment les faire revivre
comment les réveiller c'est un sacré
boulot
[Musique]